speaking of the lessons learned from the
rittenhouse case the virginia police
officer who was fired for donating to
kyle's defense fund he wants his job
back then norfolk lieutenant william
kelly donated a modest 25 bucks to help
fund rittenhouse's legal fees and that
private donation was uncovered after
hackers outed him and his donation it
went public in an article by the
guardian and now that whit written house
has been found not guilty well
kelly rightfully demands it he gets his
badge back
william kelly joins me now william this
really is one of the grossest examples
of
mob justice i have seen your message
tonight to everyone watching
i think that the written house verdict
vindicates my donation and the comments
that i made
every american has the right to express
their opinions especially when it's on a
topic that's uh being debated in the
public square and just because i'm a
police officer it doesn't mean that i
don't have that freedom anymore my
comments were
made anonymously i didn't identify
myself by name or as a police officer or
any way associated with the city of
norfolk
so the mere fact that somebody hacked
into the website was able to connect
those dots it uh doesn't mean that i did
anything wrong but i made the donation
and made those comments well cnn made
comments about your firing back in april
kelly's actions erode trust between
police and those communities that
they're sworn to protect you talk about
anger you talk about disparate treatment
this is why people are so angry in this
country wow i mean you look at that and
you know you say wow what was he
thinking oh my god these people are so
stupid william your response to these
people you apparently as a police
officer in your own free time
have no right to donate to a cause you
would like to donate to i mean you just
have no right
the city of norfolk didn't give me a
list of opinions that are approved so i
thought that as an american i can kind
of come to my own conclusion after
watching the the videos and collecting
the evidence and just uh being an
average american just
expressing his personal beliefs
but i guess if it's the wrong opinion
then
uh i should be fired and yet the police
chief who
fired you
didn't he actually attend i think i read
a blm protest is that right
you're right laura
he
took a sign
a blm sign that had the name of a person
who was recently shot by a norfolk
police officer
his sign demanded justice for that
person
at a time that the case was being
reviewed by a prosecutor's office to
determine whether or not the officer's
use of force was justified by law he uh
held that blm sign and walked in uniform
while on duty in a
blm gathering so i don't understand how
that type of behavior is so that's okay
yeah that's okay william very quickly
when police or local officials are
unable or unwilling to keep the peace
and keep people safe and their property
secure
are you surprised that citizens step in
and try to do that
and won't that happen all over the
country in these liberal jurisdictions
it's not something i would do but i can
understand the human nature the the want
to protect your community uh absolutely
and i can tell you laura those decisions
aren't being made by the officers on the
scene they're being made by the people
downtown who are
calling the shots
william thank you for appearing tonight
and good luck to you hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else